hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes in which I recap the most
ravishing language and ideas from the
last week of Wired first up today
bootlegging underwire put up a video
interview with Jason Clark who starts
the new film lawless he plays a
bootlegger and is therefore
automatically a personal hero of mine
but where did the term bootlegger come
from that emerged in the late 19th
century because people were hiding
liquor in their boots I apologize for
that not being a more intricate story
during Prohibition the term applied both
to individuals hiding hooch and to the
larger practice of smuggling alcohol by
land by sea was referred to as a rum
running because boats don't have shoes
to put the liquor in business was good
and not just because of the insane
demand during Prohibition but because
Americans have always been very fond of
alcohol in fact in the early 1800s the
average American over the age of 15 and
please note that I said 15 drink an
average of 88 bottles of hard huge each
year the problem was that we were drunk
pretty much all the time this gave rise
at the anti-saloon League the bastards
largely responsible for prohibition but
luckily the bootleggers one out soggy
socks and all up next we're wigging out
a raw file desk profile a photographer
who gives his subjects water balloon
wigs he used some high-tech gadgety to
get these shots but the wig itself has a
decidedly low-tech history now the
ancient Egyptians did not invent the big
pointy building and they weren't even
the first to wrap up dead folks for
later use as cash cows and museums but
they did Rock a mean wig it was far
easier for them to shave their heads
than it was a deal with lice which ran
rampant back then because the school
nurses that did the screenings were
total amateurs but they needed to
protect their noggins from the Sun so
they slaughtered some beeswax on their
heads and dropped on a wig made of wool
palm leaf fiber or human hair it should
be noted that the wigs did not
necessarily aim for a realistic look
which is great if you were
and all you could afford was to slap
some fruit peels on your head the
ancient Greeks and Romans used wigs as
well but after them the style fell out
of favor until the 16th century when it
was again picked up to curb lice
infestations because wigs were expensive
especially the giant fancy ones they
were mostly luxury of the upper classes
hence the term big wig they were
obsessed without wig in each other
sometimes forgetting that they had
governments and economies to run big
ostentatious wigs felt a favor yet again
at the turn of the 19th century and are
today found only in British courts where
they're used to hide liquor